wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
selber du hast auch fotos mitgebracht ja
also die fotos zeigen meine heimatstadt
in syrien
das ist die straßen der wie gewohnt
haben wirklich schön wenn ich das sehe
denke ich sofort an urlaub während
selber spricht könnt ihr gerne notizen
machen
ja es gab viele touristen als noch
frieden war aber jetzt ist alles anders
viele häuser und wohnungen sind zerstört
sehr viele menschen sind vor dem krieg
geflohen
und es kommen natürlich auch schon lange
keine touristen mehr willst du wieder
zurück denkst du oft daher muss ich
denke sogar sehr oft an meine heimat
hier ist es auch schön aber ich möchte
gerne wieder zurück nach hause
aber im moment ist das nicht möglich wir
versuchen jetzt hier ein neues leben zu
beginnen
citigroup
[Gelächter]
daran erinnere ich mich gut wären
richtig toll gefeiert
es gab so viel zu essen ist allen am
abend ganz schlecht war ihre familie ja
genau das ist meine familie
das kleine mädchen bin ich das war für
mich ein ganz besonderer tag weil ich
das erste mal mein neues kleid anhatte
zwar etwas besonderes meine eltern hat
nicht sehr viel geld damals
vielen dank für die tollen geschichten
und die fotos das war es auch schon
wieder
darf ich mit ihm und selber noch ein
foto machen
[Musik]